[Music]
okay hello everyone so
my name is junieski
last time i
one of my classes was about rook engines
and there were some broke engines left
i picked some of the
i would say most interesting ones
and but today will be a mix of
end games rook and games and also i will
pick other positions
mostly
from
strong games and then i will explain
one of
like the ideas and the most important
thing is to understand the ideas
so this is um
um
well this is a basic real game is why to
move
what we
last time we said that if the rook is
here and you can
start checking the king and he's in the
long side
then you can make a draw
but in this case
well the rook is on b2
the only difference is that the king is
too
close it is very close to the pawn
so
any thought of how can why win this
endgame
so it is a winning
position for white but there is only one
plant that wins
c1 or f1 so c1 is here
f1
here
yeah so this this move
it looks like um
it is it looks like the best mode right
so you're cutting the king off
and that was the the idea
that we talked about last time
that if the crook is in the long side
then you can make it draw here so let's
say e7
i will check everywhere here kim b6 no
chemist x is not like kind kindy six
check let's say king c5
you can still check
one more time and the king has to chase
the rook to make some progress and then
i will go
and attack the pawn
so in this case that's why um
oh it's important to know the the
previous one that if if the rook is here
and you can check
then it's a draw
well let's go back any other thought
kin ii
into d8
um the plan is to do the same right e7
well the them
if you can play e7 here with your king
on d8
yeah you will win the the end game but
if i
check you here and then i check again
king c6 we are gonna get
mostly the same position
and rook b2
and in this one
well the kin is on g6 and it this is a
this is an important point
with the key on g7
this is probably draw
and what's the idea
yeah to help the pawn to go e78
that
doesn't move rookie one and the thing is
with the king on g7 black can still play
king f8 and king king eight
but with the king here you are playing
e7 now it's too
late for this plan because after e7
then you are just promoting in one move
now check
uh the king will go to e8
and after the rook goes here well same
thing it's too late because e7 and then
you are
playing king d7 next move and promoting
let's look at the next one here
so now if the king is
not on um
oh is the other move here
but this is the the type
or here okay
yeah but a lot of answers
well the the different the difference
here is the kin is an f7 then the other
one was on g7
so we know that this doesn't work
guinea in the e8
then what works
yeah not rookie two because the big
difference is that now
only three files right so rookie two
and
check the key let's say go here check
key here
rook a1
but
yeah the separation is
for only two files
now after
broke check
this is a just an easy win
and the king goes to v7
now this one this is a very interesting
one
so here i think it's
black to move yeah it is black to move
so what
looks like white could be
winning in this engine
let me flip the board let's see if i can
flip the board
here
well you have to be careful because if i
go kim b4 and c5
then i could win the game
and
also there is there is not because i
have my pawn here
that plant doesn't work let's say check
then i go king b4 and you don't have
more checks so i could try to push the
pawn
or rook h4 after check
well if rook h4 then i will continue
moving my cane that's like in here
and
then yeah pushing my pawn pushing my
pawn
another thing that i didn't mention
today but i mentioned the last time that
i uh showed like true kangens is that
those are the end games that you have to
memorize
some of them okay you you don't need to
to to know all type of rook end games
but those you have to memorize the the
right procedure
otherwise it's almost impossible to find
the best move
in in our game
it's black to move yeah
but if i take yes
keen takes skin before
he's the egg that's the point you have
to go to c8 for the
opposition
yeah that's the only way to well black
could
uh no actually that's the only way to to
equalize because if you use this
sometimes you can do like this for
example and then kim before
check here
then rook c8
king here
check you go a6
rook c8
and if the king goes back drook
b8 but in this case rook d4 is a big
problem that's why you have to play
the move that you set rook d8 that's the
only move rook d8
um
let me promote this
if the rook moves then it's easy right
because then we bring the king to
here and we bring the king to to
uh in front of the pawn
so rook takes
queen takes and it looks like
trading rooks is not something that we
want to do when we are down a pawn in
this type of end games but after king
before we have this
only move kincaid
yeah i can see it and then the
the draw in b5 can be seven
um
and white doesn't have a way to make
progress the only is c5 and that's
already the the draw so here here are
the style mates
okay number four
now the thing is
we don't have rook d8 in this
one and if we go keen
e7
then there is the the plan of
of king before
oh let me flip
is it's black to move yeah sorry uh let
me flip the board oh no it's white to
move actually but it is with black
perfect
perspective so kim before
if let's say
c5 here
which looks good
c5
then um
that y has a the black has an
easy
procedure for the draw so c5
now well
which one
yeah rook h4
then it looks like
i mean it looks good but c6 right i'm
going to wait
actually
uh
so
here like this way
with drug c8 or
yeah i can see four and then the king is
yeah that's why it's good to know like
the the procedure to to equalize
well we already know with the pawn on c4
rook d8
equalize
now with the pawn on c5 so this is a c5
here
yeah this is the same right yeah with
the pawn on c5
um what what our first thought must be
what if we do the same
let me flip the word here
what if we
play kidney 7
and rook d8 because the big difference
is kidney 7 kc4
broke d8
take take now we don't need c8 we will
go in c7
and that's the trick but what if kim b4
so it is too late for this plant of kin
of kidney 7.
here
yeah i think kim b5 and c5
king a5
king b5
kin a6
right
attack the pawn king b5 oh no no
rook d4 yeah instead of kimbi fight rook
d4
so the king is here your rook is here
rook d4
uh yeah king b6 and then c5
but you are almost there
and what is interesting is that you
cannot defend
usually we have to defend behind the
pawn but in this when the king is
completely cut off
we cannot defend
here
so we have to defend
with the plan that you mentioned with
rook c8 that's the only plan but after
rook d4 then you have to
find the the only move
which one
or is kidney five kidney five
kidney that if rook h4 you just go here
d6
so if rook d5 then you go back that's
that's the plan that's the only plan
check
here
check
here check
keen a6 then go you go and attack the
pawn
well it looks a one then you just go
here right
so
um
if kim b5 i continue with the checks
and if uh rook d4 that's the point of
the king here with the king on g7 this
is lost because rook d4 then king b7 can
b6 and c5
but kidney five here
kidney six
so the most important here is to know
this plan with
um well if c5 for example or the pawn is
here the kidney 7 rook da that plant the
idea of going for a pawn end game which
is a draw
or
the plan that you can defend this
with the with this rook c8 giving checks
and then the kidney five
well let's jump for the next one
yeah this one is is um
a little bit easier
so
only the separation is three
files and the king is completely cut off
so the only way for white to make
progress is
what's the only way for white to make
progress here
yes that's the only way right so the
rook must be on v8 so you can
well the only way it is here here and v8
so the but the king will go c7
so here
c7
rook b8 and then the thing is you can
just
place the rook here and this is
an easy an easy draw check
and check
sorry
in the in the first game um
okay
here
oh no i'm promoting queen
so
yeah i'm promoting queen here
because it's white it's in the white
side now
yeah and then you just keep
the cane here
these two squares the rook here is just
to avoid the check
well what about this one
now the question is can you do the same
plan
oh
okay that's a good point is a draw or a
win
for
for um
white
yes
let me check let me check yeah it is
yeah
but even if it's black to move black
it's gonna just
continue here rook b3 yeah
the bridge
well like
putting the rook here on b7
because the bridge is with the with when
the pawn is uh
um
so we saw the bridge last time the
bridge is with the pawn on uh so yeah it
doesn't work with when it's a rook pawn
here
well in your line even in this rook c7
so you you
b8 so you have a couple mistakes in your
line so rugby rook c8 rook b7
rook ca loses because of kim b8 but if i
play king c8 is a draw
so who all thinks is a
draw
it is a win yeah
how is a win
here oh a a7 is is uh here no
no no this is a2 a7 is the the pawn is
on a7 so h2 here
yeah kenny e7
so the same procedure like rookie shade
king d7 rook here
then rook uh yeah c1 or a1
and then
then team b7
and if i check
you
then can
if i check
after king b7
then you will go to i'm going to
no you can't the kim i have my kin on d7
so a6 i check you again
then you go to
basics right so you have to
yeah
and that's a win
so it's a win it's a winning end game
right well but
black can defend with the king on d6
so instead of playing kindy seven so you
do the same you can do revoke h rook h2
or rook c2
look here
but
instead of going king d7 i will go king
d6
now the thing is and let's calculate it
without moving the pieces which i know
is is more difficult but it's how chess
works so
after king b7
so
let me do this here here here right here
king d6
rook here
i want kim b7 check
now you can no you cannot do the same
because if keen a6
check can b6 check
and then
you cannot go to c5
you have to go to ca
and that's that that's the trick here
qc8 check
kindy eight h1
yeah
but keaney i check keen f7
check and i take the pawn
all right
yeah the king is on this x
yeah rook has one the guinness on d8
you check where
uh you check on basics and i go k5
yeah but but then i go back here and i'm
attacking the pawn
from the back and after rookie seven
king v6
and
that's a draw
hmm
but the game i mean the end game is is
uh
he's a win for white
yeah
and yeah so the king is here in the edge
in d6
rook b6 check in c5
and now is when you have to find the
winning move here
uh the rook is on h1
blackrook
but that was the like the same the same
thing that you said before remember
check check and then i take the pawn
oh no you said kiney8 but it is the same
idea like check
queen c7 e7 or d7 then check on h7
and i take the pawn
yeah this is this is the point so
let's let's let's move the pieces now so
this is the
an end game that we have to to memorize
so the kindy d6 because if king is seven
this is
easier right here here can be seven here
then your your move wins here here in
kc5
but now if we bring the king to d6
rook b8
then you do the same
team b7 check
check
in the eight and rook h1 i'm threading
mate
but the only move to make
progress here
is rook b6 check
if you go here
yeah check
and then check and i take the pawn
so rook b6 then keen c5
uh
could you repeat that please so can
but the rook is is oh f2 here
no it is white but the rook is hanging
so the pawn is going this way
so if you go here and i take you cannot
promote it still promote queen because
of rook check
and if you try to protect the rook then
i will do the same check you here and
then i take the drug
and rookie
so there is only one winning move
here
that's the only winning move if king
takes
then you promote with check
and and actually taking the rook
and if king here well just drop c8 and
then you are promoting
next move
if rook check
you don't go here you go
c7 then check and again here
yeah this is a this is a very tricky one
but this is definitely one of the end
games that you have to memorize
because this type of end games is
um this one is very is a frequent one
well here this is black to move
how can black defend this
end game
here
yes so that's the only way to
um to to hold this onion so k7 because
even if the king goes here then you will
continue checking and once the king
moves
um and it's not protecting the pawn
then
ruger one again
attacking the point
and this is that that that draw
well now um
so i picked some interesting
um games here now we're gonna
uh move on to a middle game
and basically one of the things that i
want to to point out here is
that
this is what we want to learn from from
like ground master games
let's say here
here is i picked some a couple examples
and uh the idea is to try to understand
the move
so here is is white to move this was a
famous game
cabo blanca against lasker
and then um
so the the the other reason that i pick
these games is that then you're gonna
see how like crackney played a very
similar idea and how
he learned
from capoblanca and not only capoblanca
like fisher
and
his predecessors
so it's white to move here
i'm not getting any move from the chat
no some people are commenting but
but they are not saying anymore
okay
it's always white to move well i got one
well that move
looks interesting but it is not the move
of the game
i don't think it's the best move either
so it's just
interesting uh pawn a6 yeah
so what's your idea well i was just
thinking you could support a knight
attack
on b7
yeah
yeah 0.86 0.862
well yeah that's true so this is let's
talk about this move looks interesting
right so a6
your car kind of
you can exploit this weak square with
your knight but the thing that you have
to like consider when you are in a in
the middle game in a position like that
is okay
h6
and
knight b7 so what can i get with my
knight on b7
and then it looks like you want to keep
your knight on d6 right
and that's why a6 is possible it is i
don't think it's a mistake
but white
has better moves
than a6 it is mostly because okay you
have a very strong knight on this six
why why would i want to just put it on
b7
huh
yeah you are threatening the queen i
will play queen e7
after that and then my rook will go
probably to c8
yeah it is definitely an interesting
idea
okay that's an interesting move and
i uh one of the reasons that i picked
this game it was well the first time
that i saw this position it really
surprised me what the move that
capablanca did i would probably have
played rookie one and i also checked it
with the computer and rookie one is as
good as the the the move that capablanca
played
but um
but rookie one is good too
now i will i will give you the yeah yeah
i mean i'm just guessing e5
b5
well let's talk first about the idea of
b5 so what was your idea with b5
let's say b5
i will
[Music]
probably take or even c5 could be
possible but let's say i take
if rook takes e7 i will take with knight
and if you you still can take with
knight but
you don't want to trade off too many
pieces right in this position
but yes b5
and and yes capablanca used that plan
later
before the the move
and well i will i will say the move and
then we will talk about the move and if
one wants to if someone wants to
talk about the move that because that's
basically what i did when i was
analyzing the games i kind of
started talking with myself and trying
to understand the move and what
capablanca did was knight takes e8
now
who can think in an idea of trading a
powerful knight like this one for a
bishop on e8
so king takes
and
but do you think that
you you have already a knight on these
six
do you want to spend
more temples to to get your or not the
other night and even if you do it well
e5 is
hanging but let's say i could try to
play the knight on f7
to do it i guess the argument is
the line knight on f3
is
because
they both
well this the the the whole purpose of
these traits
is
this bishop
and light squares
and that's why i i picked this this type
of position because it's a very very
interesting position and this is the
type of thing
and the type of ideas that we have to
learn
from from the middle game
so
knight x e8 so the whole point is after
this trait
light of course are weak
and why they are wick
i have my bishop here
now uh the bishop yeah so this is a
powerful knight
another
um argument that we can make about this
trade is well
this bishop is coming to h5 and this
bishop is not active now but it will be
so why not to to trade off but the main
idea is that after this trade
then
all light squares
will become weak and now well capablanca
wants to open up the position because
you have the bishop
then pawn
takes lasker2 with this pawn this is
another or another idea or interesting
idea that we can think of so why laska
will take with the pawn that weakens the
king and not with the knights
yes so that's that's the point e6 and e5
square
right so e6 and e5 square that's why
last car two with the point
but just going back a little bit so
rookie one i checked with the computer
and it's also um mostly the same the
same evaluation
knight x8 but this is i would say it's
easier to to play now capablanca play
the b5 that you said you mentioned
before then the whole idea is to open up
the position now that you have the
bishop and e6 is still weak so the plan
is g3 rookie one and bishop h3
or could be even bishop c4
so that's the point now well we know
capoblanca i already mentioned the idea
now let's move on to the next game
it's why to move here
also you can think that you can see that
the opponent's structure is similar
the only change here is was the pawn
is now on c5 and b4 was on e5
so this was a game played by crack nick
yeah avinash found the move 98
yeah good job
and if i go knight f8 so you are if i
take you take
queen takes bishop h7 and my light
that scores will be weak and also my
king side so 96 knight f8 and i'm taking
your knight
so 96 knight f8 oh you you you gave up
you gave up no i'm still alive oh
thinking oh okay
okay because yeah
so 96 is the first move yes and then
knight c8 see if we
learn
after we know the idea right so knight
d6 is the move
strong move
uh
knight of fate is i mean knight f8 must
be played right so if bishop takes
pawn takes quintex bishop h7
dot square are wick and also the hulk
inside
so
knight f8
and then this move knight e8 so
this is definitely the bad bishop like
the worst black bishop right
but after this bishop
of the after this trade was the change
so what what change in the position here
yes
like a permanent weakness and
your bishop
now will be stronger that even this is a
bad bishop but black could play i don't
know bishop d7 bishop bishop g6
now that won't happen
and so one plan will be rookie e4 here
and put pressure on e6 and this is like
it's not that knight d6 is
um
the only
best move here
but this is the let's say the strongest
one
and it's the easiest way to play for for
white 96 knight f8
and knight c8
now something similar happened here
uh i should have picked i think
oh let me let me
pick this one first
yeah so this game
let me put it here
so lasker
this is a famous game i don't know if
someone knows the game
alaska against capoblanca
so it's white to move here
so yeah tuchar khan found the move
uh no this is not the game that the two
knights against two bishops
so james dugan that's not the game
and what's the idea
because it's an open position
and
yeah and then and
yes and
any other so after the plan the f5 any
other plan for for white
besides g4 the one that you already
mentioned
you could do it without this bishop
so but with the bishop that's not like
i know you said long term but
yeah
another plan
yeah that um
that that's a well that's that's an idea
g4 g5 f5 is the first the first move and
it's the strongest move in the position
f5
yeah the idea is basically you're
playing against this bishop
this is the
probably the strongest bishop that black
has here this is not a bad bishop but
this is this one is the strongest and
you are placing the pawns like in light
squares
now black has an advantage here which is
the pressure pair
and that's why
lasker yeah bishop f4 was the move that
i was expecting you to to to say like
bishop f4 you want to trade off the
bishop pair
and
and even though that
here these are double pawns so lasker
trade-off bishops and yeah the point is
eventually you can take and actually
lasker went to e6 with his knights in
the long term and
did the plan of e4 now d6 is weak
and well
um
[Music]
let's say black has a couple weaknesses
e6 d6 and this is the best one
f5
now we
jump for features game
so it's white to move
and yeah that's the idea and that's why
that's how we um like learn from from
the middle game about knowing this type
of plan so f4
and then f5
let's say this this was a
a rule lopez the exchange variation and
well you have to study the this pawn
structure and the plans if you let's say
you want to play that variation so f4
and then f5 with the same plan with
bishop f4
training bishops
here
if
black
trades this strong bishop for the knight
well then i could play e5 e5 later with
my rook here and white will get a very
strong initiative here
now happen in the game and white is
better then well the plan will be mostly
like the same in the other one
or you can try to push e5 too
here
now let's go back
uh
to finding this is not middle game this
is just
like this happened
in a game played by capoblanca and
lasker a blitz game
so
yes yes
well i'm answering to great wolf so you
play f5 in the position that i talked uh
before
because you want you are playing against
the other bishop the light square bishop
and yeah e4 will be
a weak pawn but
if you look the position well it's not
that weak so you can easily play rookie
a1
so knight takes
c7
knight takes
here
yes so if knight takes
that doesn't move that's a beautiful
yeah knight takes
knight takes and then rook a8
sacrificing the rook and it's the only
way to to win here otherwise it's a draw
right
so
if knight takes what sucks one then
black has to give the knight and that
happened in the blade game
we schwa
and capoblanca found it
he found it quintex and will
and b7
yeah so let's go
um
this position
okay it's white to move here
um
this is
oh but the queen on h4 is hanging
so here
hmm
and this is like in a strategic position
i'm saying that because sometimes i
showed this
position and and i got some
like
crazy tactical ideas
um
position
and
yeah the reason i i picked this one is
uh well
um actually the move the first time that
i saw it really impressed me
but
it also tells why fisher was a genius
and he was like a genius in this
not this type of position but this type
of like ideas having this type of ideas
and let me help you out with this so
well you have to either move the queen
right
or bishop g5
um
what the logical idea
is moving the queen right
but if you move the queen that's not
like a puzzle
and uh
i mean you move the queen
why
why would you want to
trade
trade off bishops
if you have the bishop pair
that's going against the rules
now the thing is
if you consider a move like bishop g5
then you have to consider like
advantages and disadvantages
so the disadvantage is well you are
trading off the bishop pair
okay let's talk about advantages
what is this
bishop g5
accomplishing
yeah that's one of the points so
with bishop g5 here
then
black has to take
and here
well
now if i will be
weaker
that where
without the bishop
and basically not only e5 like
most dark squares in the kingside are
weak
and after that
well fisher won an easy game
basically well now you are threatening
rook a8 and black has to take with the
knight
and if rook takes what rook takes and
you get the
the file and that was
actually black has to do it and that
happened in the game
then
uh
like fischer played
rook
a7
in um yeah in a similar position and won
the game i would say easily uh it took
him
a couple moves
but the the thing is
and i think fischer was a master on that
so like trading at
an advantage for another so you are
trained advantage
of the picture pair having the bishop
pair but you are getting another
advantage sometimes you might think uh
that is good and is actually bad
because you are given a bigger advantage
but in this case this is the the
strongest move in the position and also
he's going
against the rule here with bishop g5
um so this is an interesting game that i
played
a long time ago because it was 2010 i
think
it's white to move here
well abisha says rook have faded in the
previous one if rook fade i will trade
off roads and
then it's mostly the same position
bishop d2 quintex d4
yeah d2
quintex d4
um
a3 right a3 but then bishop takes rook
there is a bishop on f8 yeah
that's easy the rook on a1 is hanging
right right so bishop a3 first
yeah
yeah that doesn't move bishop a3
that's the strongest move bishop takes
rookie three and why would i want to to
trade off the bishops
yeah and then it weakens too much the
dark squares so that's the point
rookie three and then i take the bishop
and well i i won the game easily after
that and basically
um
after the game i checked it with the
computer and
and i have almost plus two in this
position already uh his last move was
was queen takes c3
but even without taking i will play
bishop a3 anyway
so and what about this one i'm playing
black here
okay yeah bishop said
bishop
sacrifice the rook so bishop three
bishop take rook takes queen takes
queen
h5 g6 queen h6 no i think that's too
much giving a rook a full rook and the
queen can go to e7
hmm
uh
gs6 right now
well
yeah g6
looks interesting
um i but i
when i was
playing here i didn't think of open up
my key inside if g6 i could with white i
could move my queen back probably
uh pontex spawntex looks like an
improvement for black
so yeah e6
looks interesting i think the the move
that i played in the game
is slightly better but yes g6
looks interesting
23 maybe yeah
no because the queen will be
under attack after pawn takes
and yeah but but still i mean you can
move the queen and now you are
threatening this i don't know but i
don't know
there is a easy
way to
to
i just thought trading and then
yeah looks good for black right
the bishop is coming to c6
attacking e4
this is not like is that black is
winning
or something but it's improving the
deposition yeah the best move is this
one
queen tags
bishop takes and then bishop da
trading this bad bishop
if so in the game
my opponent took it here rook takes d8
and
after this plan
here here bishop c6 i i won the game
yeah i would say
yeah a little
i think after bishop c6 b5 and with the
king of e7 i won the game easily
uh but if bishop e3 you mentioned bishop
e3
then bishop a5
and
well i think
and then bishop c6
so this is definitely better for for
black
bishop c6 i'm taking it
well
and i can go d5 yeah
yeah even i can go d5 right away also
but i would prefer play
bishop c6 here
and i could change the plan and
play bishop c7b52 so that's another idea
okay
yeah
yeah well the point is like uh
and also
the the two
the two games
have
like the same pattern of training the
bishop in the the right moment
and
it was i think
important for the result
so i don't know if if i would have
played another move
um i would have won this game
but
this is definitely
um very strong planning
and this one yeah so bishop a3 is the
only move that wins after bishop a3
white is completely winning
okay yeah so any question or comment
oh without without taking on c3 you mean
yes yes bishop a3 because you you want
to weaken
all dark squares so then that's why
bishop a3 was was coming even if you
play i mean let's say you play a move
like d6 and i take and let's forget that
the pawn on a6 is hanging i will
play bishop a3 anyway because all that
square will become weak after that
so that's like like the plan following
the plan
okay so another question i had so yeah
in positions where let's just say like
either light squares or dark squares a
weak but you do not both sides don't
have a bishop so like like in this case
neither side we have a dark square
bishop you would be more reluctant to
trade queensland right so that you can
use your
well if you can use the queen to i mean
if in any position if your opponent has
like some weaknesses and you have the
queen
i think it's better to to keep queens
yeah
uh but like every every every position
it doesn't that's something so that's
that's something great about about chess
like
you have to consider
like
each position individually because it's
difficult to say yeah yeah like all the
time you have to trade off and they all
keep the queen of the war because that
might be the case that it's better to
just trade off queens and the the
endgame is completely winning because
something particular in the position so
it's difficult to say well that's a good
question yeah
well any other question
okay yeah well so thank you everyone for
for coming
yeah thank you
and thank you everyone here on the chat
bye and i will see you next time
[Music]
you